the plucky youtubers behind the channel
mxr plays claim that they're being
extorted by jookin media all for
uploading some reaction videos to
youtube on the other hand jookin says
that mxr committed copyright
infringement by using their videos
without permission who's right well I
have some good news and some bad news
for mxr the good news is that they might
have a defense to jus Coons claims the
bad news is that they might not have a
defense
I have worse news still they might not
just be liable for the six thousand
dollars that you can demands but
actually six hundred thousand dollars or
more and the worst news of all there's
no way to figure out which one is right
until they go to court and spend
potentially a million dollars on
attorneys fees so who's right in this
whole reaction video debacle well let's
think like a lawyer
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because I've received hundreds
of emails and DMS about this particular
case in this particular video this case
has it all a little guy who's getting
pushed around a bad guy who might be a
troll the intricacies of copyright law
huge stakes and thousands of teenage
legal experts so let me give you a quick
summary of the facts as I understand
them because they're going to be
necessary to make any kind of legal
judgment here a few days ago the YouTube
channel mxr plays posted a video to
YouTube claiming that they were being
extorted something called the Dukan
Media sorry it feels kind of weird
talking about it because it just
happened apparently a few weeks or
months ago they have been posting
various reactions on their channel they
would take viral and meme video clips
from the Internet and the two of them I
assume that they are a boyfriend and
girlfriend couple would react to them in
some ways sometimes it would be the man
that was responding and reacting to the
clip sometimes it was the woman in mx
arm not unlike many YouTube channels
that are out there reacting to various
clips now as it happens a company called
jookin media claims that the couple used
clips from Juke ins database and jookin
appears to be sort of a middleman that
goes about clearing rights to various
viral clips if they see that a video is
trending they'll go out and they'll
reach out to the person that created the
clip and they will get the ownership
rights to these various clips so that
they can license those clips to other
people it used to be that they would
claim your videos and take the revenue
from that video strike yeah and so we
started you know removing their clips
from our videos because we're like okay
that's your clip so we won't use it yeah
so basically they just strike our
channel now whenever they see a clip
some called you can media a middleman
they themselves analogize to
shutterstock where they buy rights to
various forms of media and then sell it
to other third parties generally you can
buy a license from jookin on their
website to use their clips for $49 per
clip some called you can media a
copyright troll they specifically get
viral clip so that they can extort money
from other third parties I won't make a
judgement call as to whether they are
doing a good thing or a bad thing for
the internet but in this particular case
it appear
that mxr admit they have used various
clips that belonged to jookin i don't
know if you can actually owns the rights
to these clips but for the sake of
argument let's assume that jookin does
in fact own the copyright to these
various clips in the past jookin has
reached out to mxr and they have
demanded $2,000 from the couple for the
couple's use of various juking clips in
their YouTube channel they email us with
the bill and they charge us fifteen
hundred dollars per clip that was in our
videos and so today we got hit with a
huge bill of six thousand dollars in
total you can came back and demanded six
thousand dollars more for the use of
four other clips they didn't previously
make a demand on it was at that point
that mxr went to the Internet and as one
does when they have a youtube channel
posted a video saying that they were
being extorted by jookin for six
thousand dollars so we have paid up
about two thousand dollars in total and
now we have another six thousand dollars
to pay and if you don't pay then
basically they'll start striking your
channel mxr claims their use of these
videos is fair use of course and you can
dispute that characterization the stakes
here are incredibly high in several
respects number one jugen is asking for
six thousand dollars which for many
households that amount of money could
lead to financial ruin but additionally
when you get attorneys involved six
thousand dollars is a drop in the bucket
and we can be talking about hundreds of
thousands of dollars here but on top of
that still we're talking about copyright
strikes here and jookin has threatened
to issue copyright strikes against MSR
which means that with three copyright
strikes potentially mxr a--'s entire
channel could get deleted forever
basically go through an entire video
library most likely find three instances
of some you know random clip and then
and they'll basically remove our channel
if if we don't pay them and we don't
really have power against it we're stuck
between a hard place and a rock so I
feel like they're just constantly gonna
extort us so the stakes are incredibly
high which by the way is why I created a
course for creators called copyright
course com to deal with this exact
situation of where you are threatened
with copyright strikes and what to do if
you do get a copyright strike on your
channel so let's talk about this exact
and the law that governs this potential
dispute now first a disclaimer I don't
know all the facts I've gotten some of
the facts from Amex are what you're
going to be necessarily biased I've
gotten some of the facts from jookin
which are also going to be necessarily
biased I don't know all of the facts but
one of the good things about copyright
law is that often it just depends on the
underlying works themselves which we can
look at and we can analyze so let's talk
about copyright law in general and
specifically the copy rights one of the
biggest myths on the Internet is that if
something is out there you can use it
for almost any purpose that's absolutely
not the case if there is a clip on the
Internet someone owns it it might be
hard to track them down
but that clip whether it's a video a
sound file or a picture they belong to
someone and the default position of
copyright law is that you need
permission a license to be able to use
that underlying work whether it's a
picture or a video or what have you
however there's an exception to that
general rule that if you use that media
in a fair use way you don't need to get
permission and you also don't have to
pay a license fee but if it's not fair
use you do have to pay and the rights
holder can block you from actually using
that underlying media fair use is
incredibly complex even judges get this
wrong and often judges say this is the
most complicated portion of copyright
law in all of jurisprudence but if you
go to 17 USC 107 you will find the fair
use factors to determine whether you're
using something in fair use the fair use
Clause states that notwithstanding the
rest of the Copyright Act for purposes
such as criticism comment news reporting
teaching scholarship or research is not
an infringement of copyright and in
determining whether the use made of a
work in any particular case is fair use
the factors to be considered shall
include one the purpose and character of
the use two the nature of the
copyrighted work three the amount and
substantiality of the portion used and
four the effect upon the potential
market or value of the copyrighted work
so let's talk about that really quickly
so the first part of this section of the
Copyright Act says that generally things
that are for the purpose of commentary
and criticism can be considered fair use
now that's not dispositive but in order
to get to the rest of the factors you
generally
need a purpose that is recognized by the
fair use statute and that's not an
exclusive list of the things that
qualify as fair use but for intensive
purposes let's assume that that's the
entire universe now there are four
factors to determine whether the actual
use itself is fair use now these are
factors they're not elements you can't
just check them off and you have to
balance every single one of them and
just because you win one factor doesn't
mean that the use is going to be fair
use you have to balance all four
together and the first factor is by far
the most important this is going to be a
gross oversimplification because there
are literally millions of pages written
about fair use in American jurisprudence
a quick summary of the first factor is
that this looks to the transformative
nosov the use assuming your purpose is
recognized by the fair use statute
let's assume commentary and criticism
because that's what most YouTube use of
media falls under sometimes it's parody
but usually it's commentary and
criticism
the first factor looks at whether you
have transformed the purpose of the
original clip itself so for example a
movie review a movie review often uses
clips from the movie that it is
reviewing but it would be very very
difficult to be able to have a coherent
criticism or to be able to comment on a
movie without being able to use small
portions of the movie itself but how
does a movie review transform the
underlying movie the purpose of a movie
generally speaking is for the
entertainment value you watch a movie
because you're there to be entertained
but a movie review itself is not for the
purpose of entertainment you're not
usurping the original purpose of the
movie you are making a movie review
specifically to create commentary and
criticism about that movie that is what
we talk about when we're talking about
transformative nature of fair use and
that's what the Copyright Act
specifically carves out commentary and
criticism as a fair use so that is the
fair use purpose plus the character of
the use which is transformative the
first factor is by far the most
important and you can overcome a lot of
sins and the other three factors if you
have a highly transformative use case
with a clearly fair use commentary and
criticism purpose in your use so that
takes me to the second factor the nature
of the copyrighted work this generally
looks to whether the underlying
itself is factual or fictional in nature
copyright doesn't want to give people a
monopoly over facts so as a result
factual works things that actually
happened in real life tend to get less
protection than things that are
fictional and highly creative this tends
to be actually the least important of
the four factors factor number three
looks to the amount and substantiality
of the portion used in relation to the
copyrighted work as a whole this is
often summarized by saying that people
are only allowed to use the minimum
amount necessary the bare minimum to be
able to get their commentary or
criticism across so just because you're
giving commentary or criticism doesn't
mean you're allowed to use the entire
portion of the underlying work sometimes
you are sometimes the clips are very
short sometimes you're only dealing with
a picture which you kind of have to use
the whole thing but the bottom line is
that you generally can't use the entire
work itself or you can't use the heart
of the work itself in order to form your
commentary or criticism and finally that
takes me to Factory number four the
effect of the use upon the potential
market or value of the copyrighted work
this is actually pretty similar to the
third factor the idea is that we don't
want people using things in a fair use
way that usurps the entire market for
the original work if people are gonna
watch your video and not watch the
original video or not pay a license fee
to the original then that's a factor
that cuts against your claim of fair use
and it also kind of overlaps with the
first factor as well because the less
transformative your use the more likely
you are to use the original purpose of
the underlying work and the more likely
you are to usurp the potential market
for the underlying work and degrade the
value of that copyrighted work now if
this all sounds incredibly squishy and
ambiguous you are entirely right that's
sort of a feature not a bug though the
purpose of fair use is that this
ambiguity and the fact that it's squishy
leads to flexibility so we can carve
fair use into whatever we need it to be
and we can apply it to new situations
it's quite flexible the problem is often
you have to go to court to be able to
adjudicate these things and it also
means that there are absolutely no
absolutes you can't say that all
reaction videos are fair use some are
and some aren't it depends
the facts of the particular case so now
that you have a reasonably good
understanding of what fair use means and
its limitations and its ambiguity let's
look at the videos that mxr actually
used and which jookin claims that mxr
now owes them thousands of dollars for
having used what mxr tends to do is they
will take the general clip and then they
will inset their own video in a small
portion of the rest of the frame they'll
play the entire clip it seems and then
they will react to it
so apparently jus consent mxr a demand
letter that referenced for jookin owned
videos that were used in 3mx our
reaction videos on that basis you can
claims that mxr owes them six thousand
dollars so let's look at these different
videos so the first video that is at
issue is them reacting to a video of a
cat sticking its tongue out it's only a
couple seconds long I'm gonna zoom in on
mxr because I don't want to infringe the
copyright of the cat video owner it made
me forget about the mayonnaise and the
maggots in them so you can see it's an
incredibly short clip and there's very
minimal commentary and criticism if any
generally speaking in copyright law you
have to comment and criticize the actual
clip itself you can't use the clip to
comment on something else that's kind of
the difference between parody and satire
parody comments on the underlying work
satire comments on something else parody
is fair use often but satire is almost
never fair use the next video is of mxr
reacting to a volcano exploding
that's whoa you see the shockwave jail
for the short it's coming did you see it
dude that was awesome
what's that awesome genie that was so
awesome do you want some water so you
can see here again they're only playing
a small portion of this volcano video
but arguably that's the heart of the
volcano video you're not gonna watch the
20 minutes of the volcano not erupting
the thing you want to see is the volcano
erupting and the commentary if any is
basically that's cool which is about as
minimal as it gets now in this third mxr
video it appears that they've edited it
to remove the jookin videos I actually
couldn't find the videos that you can
references in the demand letter I wonder
if they have edited those out or maybe I
just wasn't paying attention jookin
references a girl doing a backflip and
guys lighting a trail of leaves on fire
I couldn't find that in this underlying
video but I do want to reference what
mxr says at the very beginning of this
video so it's time once again to get
genie - laughs I've come over yet
another brilliant compilation of funny
things all in the worthy endeavor of
making my beautiful darling girlfriend
laugh because she deserves happiness
they point out that Henry is showing
Genie these different videos to see if
you can get genie to laugh in my
estimation that's not really commentary
or criticism that's not a transformative
purpose and in fact by showing those
clips in full to the audience arguably
they're using the clips for the exact
same purpose as they were created in the
first place to entertain people to try
and get people to laugh and it's
entirely possible that you might not
watch the Dukan videos because you saw
basically the whole thing in mxr videos
so some of those fair use factors might
cut severely against MSRs claim of fair
use it's hard to say because we don't
have those clips in this particular
video and there might be more or less
commentary than in the prior two videos
that we looked at now the last thing i
want to point out is that in the
beginning of this video henry says that
he's not going to display the audio of a
particular clip not a juking clip I
don't think but another one because he's
worried about getting a copyright claim
related to the music and that
is bad when you're talking about
potential willful behavior which is an
issue when it comes to damages that
we'll talk about in a second so there
are a lot of bad facts in this
particular video in fact some of these
clips might be dangerously close to a
hypothetical that I use when I give
speeches about copyright and explain
things to creators an example of
something that you might think is fair
use that is clearly not fair use the
example that I come up with and this is
not an actual case this is just me
hypothesizing is that we recognize that
movie reviews are often fair use often
quintessential fair use but imagine if
you had a movie review that had the
entire movie itself it was the entire
two hour long movie and then at the end
of the movie the movie reviewer said
yeah that was pretty good or I didn't
really like that movie you've got
commentary and criticism you've got some
sort of criticism about the movie it was
good or it was bad but because you use
the entire movie itself that's clearly
not the minimum necessary and the
commentary itself is also just about as
minimal as it gets so the question of
whether
mxr henry and jeannie are actually doing
something that is fair use commentary
and criticism or copyright infringement
may turn on how courts have looked at
reaction videos in the past so let's
look at some of those cases and this is
hilarious because one of those cases
involves jookin media itself before we
get to that let's talk about my favorite
fair use case of all time and that is
the h3h3 productions case in that
particular case hilla and ethan klein
the comedy duo behind h3h3 productions
did a reaction video to a video of a man
named matt haas there was something
along the lines of parkour girl versus
workout guy which is a pretty
cringe-worthy thing where a guy kind of
stalks a woman who's working out on the
street and in that video they use almost
all of the entire clip itself but they
are also peppering the 10-minute long
video with lots and lots of commentary
the Southern District of New York which
is in the news for many different
reasons sided with
Hilla and Ethan and said that this is a
quintessential commentary and criticism
and quintessential fair use and so they
threw the case out now it was a bit of a
Pyrrhic victory because that required
100
thousands of dollars from Ethan and
hillock line to be able to get to that
stage of adjudication and that was taken
out in a very early stage on the motions
as we say in the legal field it didn't
even go to trial so if you go to trial
you can expect to pay three to four
times as much I mean honestly 800,000 to
maybe a million dollars to be able to
adjudicate that so that takes us to the
equals three vs. jookin media case a
case that actually involves jookin media
itself this is a case that is pretty
similar you have a YouTube clip show
that is owned by equals three and they
are reacting to a particular clip that
is owned by Duke and this case involved
close to 20 different clips but here's
one that is sort of emblematic of the
rest of them but you can owned a video
of a bear getting his head stuck in a
bucket and some construction workers
used a crane to get the bucket off of
the Bears head the clip show used almost
all of the clip itself and then
proceeded to talk about it for roughly
about a minute every time a bear gets is
and regarding this particular clip the
court sided with equals three and found
that this was in fact fair use if you
were to ask me what is the case that
shows the absolute bare minimum of
commentary necessary to make a fair use
claim I might point you to equals three
versus you can media which is why I have
cited to that case in almost all of my
videos that rely on fair use clips but
this case is a bit of a mixed bag the
court decided as a matter of law that
most of these clips were fair use but
also decided that some could not be
adjudicated so those would have to go to
a jury to decide and at that point the
parties settled out of court so it's a
bit of a mixed bag and jookin might have
been right on some of those clips now if
you want an in-depth analysis of the
equals three vs. you can media case
check out my friend Leonard French's
channel he goes into a huge amount of
detail about this particular case
exactly the bottom line is that this
would be an incredibly close call
nxr is skating dangerously close to the
line of it being not fair use but
there's Authority on both sides in fact
one of the cases that I would use
against it you can media if I was
representing mxr is a Kay
involving Juke and media itself but
arguments can be made on both sides if I
was representing MX art which I'm not
I'm not your attorney and this is not
legal advice I would advise them not to
go to court because I'd be worried that
number one they would lose and even if
they won they would probably have to go
all the way through trial and take it to
a jury which would incur potentially a
million dollars in attorneys fees and by
that same token stop admitting to stop
going online and admitting not only to
liability but potentially evidence that
could give rise to liability stop
posting videos and stop going on Twitter
and lawyer up and talk about what your
rights are before you start digging
yourself into a bigger hole than you
already have on the other hand if I was
jookin media's attorney which I'm not
this is not legal advice I would
probably tell them the same thing that
this is not something you'd want to go
to court over they've lost on this
before and that you're dealing with
potentially not only losing this battle
not only in court but in the court of
public opinion but potentially attorneys
fees are on the line one of the things
about copyright law is that sometimes
the loser has to pay the winners
attorneys fees
it gets really dicey I don't know that
this is one of those cases but it could
be on the line but they're bad facts and
there's bad law for both sides this is
not something that either side wants to
take to court and the stakes are
incredibly large I talked about earlier
that mxr might be on the hook not just
for the six thousand dollars that you
can request but actually six hundred
thousand dollars the reason is that when
you're talking about copyright law not
only do you have to deal with what are
called actual damages the out-of-pocket
loss that someone has suffered but you
also have statutory damages and in some
circumstances where you have a willful
act by the copyright infringer you can
get a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
per infringement so those four different
videos that may or may not have
constituted copyright infringement could
mean that mxr was on the hook for six
hundred thousand dollars in statutory
damages that would be up to the court on
top of that attorneys fees are on the
table as well which might even be more
than six hundred thousand dollars if
this was taken to court not to mention
since we're dealing with DMCA takedowns
and YouTube strikes that their channel
might be deleted which is
is their major source of income for the
household it's just constantly in the
fear of our channel being deleted so
given the thousands potentially millions
of dollars at stake is this extortion by
jookin media against Henry and Jeanne an
mxr well almost certainly not at least
not the legal definition of extortion
this might constitute the sort of
colloquial understanding of extortion of
a bad guy pushing a small person around
but it's almost certainly not legal
extortion we'll talk about whether
jookin is a copyright role in a second
but in general to be able to form a
claim for extortion under at least the
federal statute in 18 USC 1951 you have
to have a wrongful claim you know it has
to be disconnected from a claim of right
jookin claims to have a good faith
belief that this is copyright
infringement and on the facts as I see
them they could very well have a
meritorious copyright claim it's hard to
say it could go either way but because
of that essentially what they're doing
is they're just making a demand which
potentially is legal against someone who
is a potential copyright infringer
jookin media actually left a comment on
MX ARS YouTube channel saying hi we'd
like the chance to respond to this for
starters it's important to understand
that we provide a service for video
creators we allow them to list their
content on our website so the TV shows
publishers youtubers influencers or
advertisers can buy license to use their
content we have no ill will towards you
or your channel in effect you are taking
other people's videos without asking
them then posting them to your channel
and making money off of them we never
want to issue copyright strikes we have
a duty to do so to protect the copyright
of the creators who have signed with us
again there's no reason we can't work
together so that you can have access to
amazing videos and that creators of
those videos share in the economics of
course you can says they don't want to
issue DMCA takedowns and the reason is
because there are actual legal
repercussions for levying those DMCA
takedown notices so of course they don't
want to do that and they don't want to
take people to court because it's
incredibly expensive and they might lose
but that's why some people called you
can media a copyright troll they get the
copyrights to various viral videos and
then make demands for serious money from
people that have used those clips in
other media I reached out to both mxr
and you can about this particular
dispute you can go back to me and
provided this statement they say that
they
consider fair use but they feel that mxr
as videos don't rise to the level of
fair use and they point out that they
have paid out over twenty million
dollars to people whose videos they have
licensed but we don't know what
percentage of Judkins revenue comes from
making these demands versus proactively
licensing this material and in some
sense having middlemen like this can be
a very good thing because it's often
very very hard to know who owns the
rights to these various things someone
owns the rights to these viral clips but
often big businesses will not use them
because they might not be able to track
down who owns them and having a
middleman like jookin can help solve
that problem and create revenue from
licensing that otherwise simply wouldn't
exist now if you want more detail about
whether this constitutes extortion and
the requirements for extortion I
recommend checking out fellow YouTube
lawyer Richard Hogg's channel where he
goes into a lot of depth about this now
I disagree with him about the dollar
amounts themselves being potential
evidence of a claim of extortion just
actually $1500 per fence is a pretty
small amount if I'm honest I know it can
be a huge amount to small youtubers out
there but in the world of copyright law
it's a very very small amount and it is
dwarfed by the potential devastating
effects of statutory damages or an award
of attorneys fees in an actual lawsuit
over this case one of the more famous
extortion cases is the case of autumn
Jackson and Bill Cosby autumn Jackson
claimed that she was the daughter of
Bill Cosby before he was outed as a
sexual predator and extorted him said
that she would ruin his squeaky-clean
reputation in the news media by sewing
these potentially untrue allegations
that he had fathered her out of wedlock
and one of the cases that Richard Hogue
mentions in his video about this case is
the Michael avenatti cases is ongoing
that hasn't led to a resolution but one
of the things that Michael avenatti is
accused of having done is to extort a
settlement out of Nike not for his
client but for a multi-million dollar
consulting gig for himself lawyers are
not allowed to negotiate on their own
behalf
at the expense of their client and so
that could conceivably give rise to
extort
Michael have 90 just lost a motion to
dismiss that legal claim so it's going
to go to trial we'll see if he's
convicted on that but when a lawyer
tries to get something from a party that
they're not legally allowed to ask for
like a consulting gig worth millions of
dollars for their own behalf that could
potentially give rise to extortion
whereas here mainly what's happening is
that jookin is asking for payment for
copyright infringement and as we've
talked about before whether copyright
infringement occurred or not or whether
it's fair use or not is certainly an
open question by the way some have said
that YouTube should just shut this down
jookin is abusing the copyright system
regardless of the underlying claims and
that YouTube should just remove their
ability to make these claims well the
problem is this isn't really YouTube's
system this is not Content ID what you
can is talking about here is issuing a
DMCA takedown this is written into the
Copyright Act section 512 if there is
infringing material on a website
including YouTube you are allowed to
issue a DMCA notice and have it taken
down YouTube has implemented a version
of that which incurs a strike when you
get a DMCA claim but there are also ways
to fight DMCA claims which I've covered
in my copyright course
so effectively YouTube has to follow the
law when they get a DMCA claim they have
to take the video down they can't ignore
it and they can't stop people from
issuing DMCA claims it's written into
the copyright law that they just
basically have to follow and if jookin
does actually have a claim then they
have every right to issue a DMCA
takedown now the Ninth Circuit law under
Lenz says that they have to have a good
faith belief that they have a claim of
copyright infringement and they have
taken into consideration fair use before
they have issued that DMCA takedown but
look if they have a claim they have a
right to issue a DMCA takedown in a
copyright strike this is serious
business
I get copyright claims all the time on
my channel but I'm very confident in my
fair use because number one I have a law
degree I have over a decade of
experience as a trial lawyer and
copyright lawyer and I know what I'm
talking about the big businesses have
lawyers who know this stuff inside and
out because the operative word here is
that it is a
business and we've talked about the
copyright implications but let's talk
about these sort of business law related
things here and even though I am NOT mxr
as lawyer and this is hashtag not legal
advice what I can say to mxr is you need
a lawyer this is a business and you
can't go around just floundering around
thinking that you're going to be safe I
asked my friend Roberto Blake who knows
the business of YouTube better than
everyone what he thought about this
situation and here's what he said
I think when you are a full-time content
grader when you have a very significant
channel like in this situation that you
have to really think of things like a
business and you have to deal with
jookin media like a business they aren't
really going to care too much about the
court of public opinion this isn't like
a youtube drama situation we're calling
them out really is that meaningful
youtubers tend to get very invested
emotionally in these situations when the
real answer is to step back treat it
like a business and call your lawyer and
let them deal with it because this is a
business-to-business situation and you
really want to play your best cards and
when you take the the step of just
trying to out them in social media or do
something like that
you're playing more the game like a
youtuber than like an entrepreneur and a
business person that's trying to protect
what they've built and that's exactly
right there are huge consequences here
and you have to lawyer up either way mxr
who says that they don't have a lawyer
well they need to get one and Geney says
that she spent half an hour going
through Juke ins videos well number one
that is not enough time and number two
you can't unring the Bell some have
argued that look jookin admits that the
license fee is only $50 why can't mxr
just pay $200 $50 for each video and
then everyone can go on their merry way
well the problem is that you're dealing
with copyright here once you have
committed copyright infringement and I'm
not saying that mxr has committed
copyright infringement or that they
can't use the fair use defense they may
not I'm committed infringement and they
may have that defense if you infringe
the copyright you can't then go back
through the database and buy the license
that's simply not enough there are
statutory fees which are
huge and it costs money to get lawyers
involved so once the horse is out of the
barn you can't put it back in again if
you steal a car you can't avoid jail
time by giving it back to the owner and
it seems that mxr has already dug
themselves further into the hole by not
having a lawyer they said that they
already paid $2,000 to jookin related to
two different videos and then jookin
came back well yeah when you feed the
trolls they come back for more clearly I
realize our mistake was paying the first
time because now they're like oh we have
we asked someone we could just easily
just get easy money out of a comment and
lawyer probably would have made you can
sign a release of all claims so that mxr
wouldn't admit liability and it would
make sure that you can couldn't come
back for more after they paid the two
thousand dollars but because they didn't
sign a release so you can can come back
over unadjudicated claims which is
exactly what you can did additionally a
lawyer would have negotiated it down
jookin has basically admitted that a
reasonable license for these clips is
$49 which would mean that nxr should pay
a hundred and fifty dollars not six
thousand dollars but the problem is that
because they didn't have any foresight
they didn't have a lawyer they didn't
know what they were doing when it came
to copyright they could be liable for
thousands more not just the six thousand
dollars that you can claims but
potentially hundreds of thousands of
dollars in statutory fees also a word of
caution to mxr mxr has already linked to
a video that takes MX r's side by a
channel called the quartering be very
careful about listening to that advice I
strongly suggest mxr stand up and tell
him to get bent and tell him to sue him
and when they issue a copyright strike
on the channel I would I would dispute
it and I would say take me to court I
don't think they're willing to do that
as a company but it's not my money
I'm sorry if this sounds harsh but Juke
ins claim isn't necessarily facially
invalid this is a case that could go
either way
what mxr has done might be fair use but
it also might not be fair use it would
be up to a judge or a jury and
reasonable Minds can differ that's what
happens when you go to court you kind of
roll the dice certainly lawyers who I
have talked to about this very case have
differing ideas about it and I would
love love to tell you that mxr is
clearly in the right and jookin is
clearly in the wrong I hate the way that
they've gone about trying to get money
from mxr but I don't know that that's
the case
I love creators and I want them to
create more art but we all have to
operate within the confines of the way
the law actually is not the way that we
want it to be and it's possible maybe
even probable that mxr is wrong an mxr
isn't quite as small as they claim they
can't stick their head in the sand
trolls like this go out and they look
for deep pockets
the thing is jookin has taken this to
court before and effectively they've won
we don't know the actual outcome because
there was a settlement but odds are you
can got the better of that particular
case and even winning can be losing in a
situation like this vindicating your
rights could easily take half a million
dollars in attorneys fees just ask Ethan
Klein from h3h3 it took hundreds of
thousands of dollars they went through
$200,000 in one month to ultimately be
successful in their claim so don't
assume that you can start a GoFundMe
over that jookin doesn't care about what
you think about it a judge doesn't care
about your Twitter clout or bad Yelp
reviews so just be very very careful
about whose advice you listen to and
again the best thing you can do is talk
to an attorney and I've represented
clients on both sides of the copyright
coin I've represented clients who I've
had to defend against meritless claims
of infringement and I've also
represented clients who have had their
work stolen by others and had to defend
their rights it's always a big deal and
it's always messy and as roberto blake
said they need to think about their
youtube channel as a business mxr plays
gets 900,000 views on average per day
sometimes well over a million views a
day at a conservative CPM of $6 with the
YouTube split if monetize their channel
would get roughly 2,500 to $3,000 per
day that equates to a million dollars
per year that's not a small business
that is a medium-sized business and they
need a lawyer now I understand that
there's a controversy about whether
their YouTube channel is monetized or
not but I also understand that they have
tens of thousands of patrons on patreon
and at a minimum if they're paying one
to two dollars per month that means that
they're earning
potentially a quarter of a million
dollars per year just on patreon alone
you can't get away with thinking that
this is just mere YouTube drama this is
real life the stakes are incredibly high
there are hundreds of thousands of
dollars at stake here you might end up
in federal court and this is not just a
word of warning to mxr but this is a
warning to anyone with a youtube channel
mxr says that they're worried they might
have to stop reacting to videos and that
they might just react to pictures
instead number one if you are doing
things in a fair use way then there's no
need to stop but I think they need to
ask themselves whether they are very
very certain that they have met the fair
use requirement and at this point it's
like I feel like we can't even watch any
videos anymore
we can't react to any videos period like
we can only look at images and pictures
and I will say that it is just a myth
that they could forego the videos and
start reacting to pictures instead
because pictures are copyrighted as well
and they might run into exactly the same
problems that they run into with videos
which is one of the reasons I gave a
talk called the 11 myths of copyright on
the Internet if you're a content creator
and you would like to see this free
video you can check out the link in the
description it's part of my course that
I created for creators out there who
don't have lawyers necessarily but they
need to be protected when they are
making videos on the Internet that's why
I created copyright course calm it is
specifically created for creators to
tell them what their rights are and to
give them the tools that they need with
it when they find themselves looking
down the barrel of a copyright strike
potentially getting their channel
deleted it gives them the tools that
they need including the actual language
that I have used as an attorney to fight
off dozens of different copyright claims
by underlying rights holders I have
never lost a claim because as I said
before I know what I'm doing and you can
use the exact same templates that I use
when I am fighting copyright trolls on
the internet so check out the links in
the description you can check out the
free video 11 myths of copyright or you
can go straight to copyright course com
to get the copyright course which I
created so that other creators will not
be in the same situation that mxr plays
find themselves in so do you agree with
my analysis do you
think that mxr is being extorted or that
maybe they committed like copyright
infringement how do you think that this
would turn out in court based on the
precedents that we talked about here
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
that contains all of my other real law
reviews where I talk about legal issues
in the news including impeachment and
tons of other copyright related things
and check it out and I will see you in
court